so it says here that you know because
i'm a big just invest in the s p index
fund i don't do individual stocks you
know who knows what's happening with the
market who knows what's happening with
tesla but i'm very confident that the s
p is going to go ten percent year over
year every year as it said so let me
just read you some numbers here if you
invest ten thousand dollars
uh in the s p index in 2007 you'd be
sitting on 71 grand right now so
7x your money if you invested that 10k
uh into an index cards for trading it'd
be worth 165 grand not so bad so over
double that so
um to your point picking out cards
individual uh individuals is there an
actual
index
for cards like if i said look i don't
know if
i want a tray young or a zion or a brady
i don't want the responsibility of
picking this one card whether it goes up
or down who knows is there an index that
people can invest in just like the s p
500 no there there are funds out there
there are a couple card funds out there
i know that a company called alt has a
has a fund i know that blowout has the
wax fund which uh i like as well and i
know that there are
other entities that i think they're
doing it more for uh for private clients
there are indexes like if you go get an
app called card ladder um it is a
pricing tool and they have like an app
of you you can check sports by basically
typing baseball basketball and they have
a bat they have a basket of the most
highly collected uh cards and they show
you what the trend is on that individual
card but no
as as it gets bigger it would be great
if there were
uh readily
accessible funds the closest thing to it
now that you can buy without being an
accredited investor is probably the
fractional share companies um you know
whereby you can buy an individual like
hey you want to go out and get mickey
mantle cards you know buy shares of
mickey mantle cards or buy shares of
michael jordan or lebron james that's
the closest thing to it what are those
companies called again uh you've got
rally you've got otis you've got
collectible there's a new one coming out
with some ultra high-end uh items called
liquid marketplace i think they're
launching in the next month or two
but those are four groups
that would be um you know if you're
looking to do that type of thing if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]